(chill music)
- [Joey] Welcome to
where the magic happens.
You've seen this place before
mostly in the background
of these A-roll shots
and in B-roll shots where
I'm either wasting time
or being productive, the only
two types of B-roll shots
on this entire channel.
But anyways,
today, we're gonna go over
this home office setup of mine in detail
so that you guys can spend more time
on the things that fulfill you
and that will move your life forward,
rather than slipping deeper and deeper
into the endless abyss of
algorithmically curated content
like this video.
Also, like this video.
Let's jump into it.
The theme that I had in mind
when I was designing this space
was minimalism.
It's because I'm very original
and unlike any other
productivity YouTuber.
The goal of a productivity space
should be to reduce the friction
in the way of doing the important things
that you have to do in a day.
You wanna make sure that
everything on your desk
facilitates a concentrated flow state,
because getting into that flow state
is more important than
anything in the world.
It's even more important
than spending quality time with your son.
I think that's what Gary V told me.
So, how do I achieve that flow state?
Well, let's get into some specifics.
The thing that I look at all day long
is my LG UltraFine 4K monitor.
The thing I really like about this monitor
is that it has a USB-C port on the back.
So, I only have one cable to connect
to my MacBook Pro that
transfers audio, power, display.
It really helps play into
this minimalist vibe.
The reason why I went with
this monitor specifically
is because it's tack sharp.
It wasn't too expensive.
The blacks are nice and deep,
and it is very color accurate.
So, I really enjoy editing videos on here
because I get an accurate representation
of what the image actually looks like.
The monitor is connected
to my daily driver
which is the 16-inch MacBook
Pro with the M1 Max chip.
This is like the premium,
top of the line Apple device
right now.
It absolutely shreds 4K video.
It's crazy to me that
this thin slice of metal
is all I need to run a production company
that uses cutting edge 4K
video, multiple layers of it.
And this thing doesn't flinch.
The only downside is the cost.
This thing costs more than
I pay my assistant Jared
in a year, but that
actually doesn't bother me.
Sitting right next to it is
the new AMD Razer Blade 14,
which I mostly use for gaming.
But because this is a productivity
channel, that was a joke.
I use it for programming.
This beautiful, sexy
keyboard is the Keychron K6.
I learned about this keyboard
by watching an Ali Abdaal video,
where he was going over
a bunch of different mechanical keyboards.
Basically, he was
investigating which keyboard
would help him type the fastest.
This keyboard scored one
of the lowest scores.
And he said that the build
quality wasn't impressive at all
and it kind of felt like a toy.
But I thought it looked cool
so I bought it immediately.
And the mouse I use is
the Razer DeathAdder 2.
I came to the decision to buy this mouse
because I was playing "Rust,"
with my brother last week
and I was trying to flick
on kids with the bow,
and I was just missing all my shots
because I'm shit at "Rust."
But naturally, I blamed the mouse.
And my mouse at the time was
the Logitech MX Master 2S.
But I'm starting to realize
that it's actually kinda shit.
There's a ton of input lag
which makes it actually
less accurate to use,
even if you're not gaming.
There was a delay between
when I moved my hand
and when the mouse moved.
So to solve this issue, I picked
up the Razer DeathAdder V2,
and I noticed an immediate difference.
This thing has basically zero
milliseconds of input lag.
When I move my hand,
the mouse moves in perfect sync with it.
Even for video editing,
I'm way less clumsy
and I can click on things more accurately,
which probably saves me a lot of time
and mental energy subconsciously.
It's probably not that
big of a difference.
I'm not gonna pretend that
changing your mouse out
to like a slightly higher
refresh rate or response time
will change your productivity forever.
But I'm a bit of a snob
and I do this for a living
so I can get away with spending money
on things that I don't actually need.
Moving on.
So, I'm a big audio guy.
A lot of you guys say, "Your
voice just sounds so crisp.
Why does it sound so crisp?"
Well, partly it's because
of this mic I'm using.
I'm probably not gonna
give it a shout out.
But a lot of that is because
I'm a bit of an audiophile.
And I maintain that the
best bang for buck speakers
you can get for under $200,
if you want just like a
nice little easy thing
to buy on Amazon, get
these out of Edifiers.
I can't remember what they're called
but the link will be in the description.
I've used a bunch of different, small,
budget-friendly studio monitors before,
but I always come back to the Edifiers
because I think they just
punch well above their weight.
On Amazon, these speakers
are around $150 Canadian,
which is probably like a buck 50 US.
So, pick them up.
They're very cost effective.
But if you want premium sound quality,
these Edifiers aren't it.
You're gonna be spending
a thousand dollars plus
on a pair of studio monitors,
if you want something like
truly audiophile status.
But if I'm sound mixing, I'm
not using my speakers anyways.
I'm using my headphones.
And that's where my Beyerdynamic
DT 990 Pros come in.
These are also budget friendly,
but I've literally never heard
a better sounding pair of headphones.
These things make listening
to music an absolute joy.
They make mixing audio an absolute joy.
Everything has a certain
level of clarity and purity
with these headphones, and I'm a huge fan.
(mouse smashing)
The only issue that might be an issue,
depending on how you use them,
is that when you put them
on, they are not isolating.
So, you can kinda of hear
everything around you.
So if you work in a busy coffee shop
or a noisy environment with
a lot of ambient noises,
then I wouldn't recommend
these headphones.
But for this very quiet office
on the top floor in a random house
in the middle of suburbia,
it works great for me.
I run both the speakers and the headphones
through the Scarlet 2I2.
This is by far the least
interesting piece of tech
in this whole video.
So, I'm just gonna move on.
But I like it.
I use it. It works.
To the right of my desk is my whiteboard.
And there used to be a whole
bunch of stuff on here.
An attack plan, marketing strategy,
product list, video ideas.
We used to just fill the board
with like the entire
Better Ideas strategy,
courses that we could launch,
products we can make, bla di bla di bla.
But what ended up happening
was analysis paralysis.
When there was too many
things on the board,
we didn't really know what
to do every single day.
And by we, I mean Jared and I.
Jared, who helps me with videos
and his desk is over there,
but we're not gonna cover his desk.
I don't know how proud he is of his desk.
But anyways, we basically erased
pretty much everything on the whiteboard,
save for a few key things
that we kinda need to remember
on a day-to-day basis.
And we've replaced it with this little box
that has the one thing.
It is the most important
thing we have to do each day.
And we spend half an hour
evaluating what this one thing is.
And we pretend that nothing else exists.
We don't think about anything else
until this one thing is done.
And the result is that our
productivity has skyrocketed.
Once we have done this one thing,
not only do we do the most important thing
with clarity and focus,
but we're more inspired to
tackle all the other bullshit
that we would have had on there.
So, it's a win-win.
And the last thing I wanna
mention is my gaming setup.
And you might say, "Joey,
this is a productivity video.
Why do you keep on reverting
this back to gaming?"
Well, I have a problem with gaming
and I'm really trying to work on it.
But I do think there's
something to learn here.
I just can't stop playing video games.
So basically, my Xbox is below my desk,
out of sight and out of mind.
The Xbox being below my desk
provides a lack of visual cue.
So, I don't get interrupted
in the middle of being productive
and tempted to play Xbox
and sweat "Halo Infinite."
But I also keep my gaming monitor
at the base of this shelf.
So that every time I wanna game,
I have to walk over to
the monitor, pick it up,
bring it to my desk, hook it up.
And you might be saying,
"Joey, why don't you just hook
up your Xbox to the monitor
that you seem to be so
high about on your desk.
So that all three of your devices
are nice, and streamlined,
and minimal."
But the problem is while
the display is quite nice
and it's sharp, and it has deep blacks,
and it's nice to look
at for color grading,
it's only 60 FPS and
I'm not a filthy casual.
I stole this plant for my sister.
So, it makes my office set up
look more zen or some shit.
But that's pretty much it, guys.
I don't really know what
else to talk about in here.
But hopefully, you guys
have a little bit of an idea
of how I choose to operate
my productivity setup.
And maybe you guys got a
few ideas. I don't know.
Maybe you were just entertained,
but that's pretty much it.
You guys can stop asking
for this type of video,
unless you really liked it.
And this video does really well
and it gets tons of view or something,
in which case, I'll just do it again.
A big thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes
for anyone who loves learning
and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills.
If 2022 is the year that you told yourself
you're gonna finally learn
programming, or cooking,
or get better at photography,
then Skillshare is the
perfect place to start.
One of my main priorities for this year
was to just sort of organize
my life, top to bottom.
My financial life, my personal
life, my professional life.
So, that 2022 seems just simpler.
I want things to be simpler,
not as chaotic as they were in 2021.
And for that reason, I
turned to my boy Thomas Frank
who's the master of this kind of thing.
And he has the perfect class for me,
which is basically organizational
workflow for creatives.
So if you're a writer, a
photographer, a videographer,
or anybody who likes to produce
more than they consume, ideally,
then I highly recommend
this class by Thomas Frank.
That will help you spend more time
doing the things that you
love and that fulfill you,
rather than consuming "Halo Infinite,"
and smiling "Friends,"
clips on YouTube all day.
And that basically sums up
Skillshare in a nutshell.
It's always super easy
to take whatever you're
learning on Skillshare
and apply it directly to
your real life pursuits,
whatever those may be.
So if you guys wanna make
2022 a year of growth,
then I highly recommend
checking out Skillshare
using my link in the description below.
The first a thousand of you
will get one month of Skillshare free.
So, go ahead and hit up that
link, learn something new,
explore your creativity and
as usual, have a great time.
If you like this video,
make sure you actually
hit the Like button.
Because when you hit the Like button,
the algorithm goes oh, this
might have actually been
an above average video
and more people should know
about this type of content.
That really helps me out.
And it potentially helps other people out.
So, it's just a win-win if you
actually click that button.
If you're lurking here,
consider subscribing and
checking out the second channel
where there is more meme
content, more enjoyable content.
I don't know if it's more enjoyable,
but it's definitely meme and more chaotic.
And also follow the brand
new Instagram that we got.
We're kind of lacking in
the followers department,
but I'm gonna do a giveaway
on there very soon.
Last time we had a giveaway,
we gave away a bunch of Kindles.
But yeah, your chances of
winning are pretty high
because there's like
no subscribers on there
or no followers on there.
So yeah, give it a follow.
That's all for today.
Thank you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.
Also, go outside.
It's probably really nice where you are.
Even if it's not nice
where you are, go outside.